En este video vamos a trabajar con funciones
cuadráticas como esta f(x) = ax² + bx + c,
que, como sabemos, al graficarla en el plano se
generará una parábola como ésta, o como ésta otra,
o ésta otra. Podemos tener funciones cuadráticas
cuyas parábolas abran hacia abajo o hacia arriba,
algunas abiertas o estiradas, otras cerradas o
comprimidas. También se podría generar un arco
de parábola si limitamos el dominio de la función
cuadrática. Por ejemplo aquí: tenemos el arco
de la parábola de esta función cuadrática
en el intervalo cerrado de 0 a 10. Ahora,
te invito a pensar en algo totalmente diferente:
¿se puede describir la posición de la parábola
en un sistema de coordenadas rectangulares, que
representa a una función cuadrática sin necesidad
de graficar? Pausa el video y piénsalo. Bueno,
la respuesta corta es sí: se puede describir
la posición de la parábola en un sistema de
coordenadas rectangulares que representa a
una función cuadrática sin necesidad de graficar
a partir de los valores que tomen a, b y c. Pero,
¿por qué pasa esto? Para tener una idea de la
posición de una parábola, pensemos en los ceros
de la función. Recuerda: definimos a los ceros
de una función como los valores de x que cumplen
que f(x) = 0. También, sabemos que los valores
de x, donde tenemos un 0 de la función f(x),
son aquellos valores donde la función interseca
al eje de las abscisas, es decir, al eje X. Si
nada de esto te parece conocido, te invito a que
revises los videos sobre funciones cuadráticas en
Khan Academy. Pero, ¿cómo podemos encontrarlos?
Existen varios métodos para encontrar los valores
de x que satisfagan la expresión f(x) = 0, es
decir, f(x) = ax² + bx + c = 0. Para obtenerlos,
vamos a utilizar la fórmula general para resolver
ecuaciones de segundo grado. La fórmula general
para encontrar las soluciones o ceros de
una función cuadrática f(x) = ax² + bx + c
es: x = -b ± √b² - 4ac, todo esto dividido entre
2a, siempre y cuando a sea distinto de 0. Ahora
bien, ¿cómo podemos utilizar esta información
para describir la posición de la parábola en
un sistema de coordenadas? Cuando resolvemos una
fórmula cuadrática, podemos obtener tres posibles
escenarios: el primero es tener dos raíces o
ceros, el segundo es obtener una única raíz o
cero y el último es obtener cero raíces o ceros
de la función cuadrática. Podemos saber este
resultado calculando el valor del discriminante
en la fórmula general para los valores de los
coeficientes de la función cuadrática. El
discriminante de la ecuación cuadrática es la
parte interna de la raíz cuadrada en la fórmula
general, es decir: b² - 4ac. Y, ¿cómo podemos
interpretar el resultado del discriminante
con respecto a los valores de nuestra función
cuadrática? Veamos. Si el discriminante
es 0, entonces toda esta parte se cancela,
porque la raíz de 0 es 0, y sumar o restar 0 es
dejar -b sin cambio. Entonces, en este caso, el
resultado es -b / 2a, que es un único valor, por
lo que tenemos una única raíz o 0. ¿Cómo podemos
observar este resultado al representar la función
cuadrática en el sistema de coordenadas? Bueno,
lo que nos dice este resultado es que la ecuación
sólo interseca al eje X en un punto, su vértice,
por lo tanto, en este caso tendremos una parábola
que toca al eje horizontal en un sólo punto,
de esta forma o de esta otra. Bien, y este es el
primer caso, cuando el discriminante, es decir,
b² - 4ac = 0, ¿cierto? Ahora ¿qué pasará si el
cálculo del discriminante resulta ser mayor que
0?, es decir es un resultado positivo. En la
fórmula general tenemos que: b² - 4ac, esto es
positivo. Entonces, la raíz cuadrada de un número
positivo siempre existe. Podemos observar que,
cuando el discriminante es positivo, tenemos dos
posibles raíces o ceros de la función cuadrática:
x₁ = -b + √b² - 4ac / 2a y x₂ = -b - √b² - 4ac
/ 2a. Este resultado nos indica que vamos a
intersecar el eje de las abscisas, el eje X,
en dos valores: x₁ y x₂, por lo tanto nuestra
parábola se puede ver de esta forma o de esta otra
forma. Recuerda: en el segundo caso, el valor del
discriminante es positivo, por lo tanto tenemos
dos intersecciones con el eje horizontal. Bien,
por último, pensemos en lo que pasará si el
discriminante, es decir si el valor de b² - 4ac
˂ 0, es decir, es negativo. Tenemos, entonces, que
la raíz cuadrada del discriminante es indefinida,
ya que no podemos sacar la raíz cuadrada de
un número negativo. Así que en este caso no
hay forma de obtener las raíces o ceros de
la función cuadrática; esto quiere decir que
si el discriminante es menor que 0 entonces no
intersecamos al eje de las abscisas, es decir el
eje X. En este tercer caso, tendremos parábolas
como ésta o como ésta otra; pero esto último es
un tema avanzado que aprenderás más adelante. Muy
bien, con esto acabamos de entender qué nos dice
el discriminante acerca de la representación
gráfica de nuestra función cuadrática en un
sistema de ejes coordenados: si el discriminante
es positivo, entonces intersecamos al eje X en
dos valores, por lo tanto, la gráfica de la
función cuadrática se verá de esta forma;
si el discriminante es 0, entonces intersecamos
al eje X en sólo un valor, que nos da el vértice
de la parábola y, por lo tanto, se va a ver de
esta forma. Por último, pero no por eso menos
importante, si el discriminante es menor que 0,
entonces la parábola no interseca el eje X, por
lo tanto la gráfica de la ecuación cuadrática se
puede ver de esta forma. Veamos algunos ejemplos
para entender mejor esta idea del discriminante
y su utilidad en la descripción de la parábola
sin necesidad de graficar. Primero, tenemos
la función cuadrática f(x) = 9x² + 12 x + 4.
¿Cuántas intersecciones tiene en el eje de
las abscisas? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bueno, calculemos su discriminante. Sabemos
que el discriminante se calcula con b² - 4ac,
en este caso: a vale 9, b vale 12 y c vale 4;
entonces, si calculamos el discriminante, éste
nos queda como: b² - 4ac es lo mismo que 12² - 4
(9)(4), y esto es lo mismo que 144 -9 * 4 = 36,
36 * 4 = 144, 144 - 144, esto es lo mismo que 0.
Y ahora recordemos, ¿cómo se ven las gráficas de
las parábolas cuyo discriminante es 0? Bueno,
serán parábolas que tocan con su vértice y por
lo tanto sólo en un punto al eje horizontal,
entonces tendremos una parábola como ésta. Ojo,
esta parábola abre hacia arriba porque el signo
del coeficiente a es positivo. Bien, ahora ¿cómo
se verá la gráfica de la función cuadrática
f(x) = -x² - x -1? Pausa el video e inténtalo.
Bueno, utilicemos la fórmula del discriminante. Si
a = -1, b = -1 y c = -1, entonces b² - 4ac = -1,
esto elevado al cuadrado, -4(-1)(-1), y esto
es lo mismo que: 1 - 4, lo cual es -3. Tenemos
un discriminante negativo, lo que significa que
nuestra parábola no interseca el eje X, y como
a tiene signo negativo, entonces es una parábola
que se va a ver de esta forma. Bien, ahora ¿cómo
se verá la gráfica de la función cuadrática f(x)
= 2x² -11x + 5? Pausa el video e inténtalo. Bueno,
usemos de nuevo la fórmula del discriminante: si a
= 2, b = -11 y c 5, entonces b² - 4ac = -11, esto
elevado al cuadrado, -4(2)(5), lo cual es 121 - 4
por 2 es 8, 8 por 5 40, menos 40, y eso nos da 81.
Ahora tenemos un discriminante positivo, lo que
significa que nuestra parábola interseca al eje X
en dos valores. Si queremos saber en qué valores
corta el eje X, entonces terminemos de resolver
la fórmula general para obtener los valores de
intersección: x₁ = -b + √b² - 4ac / 2a, así que
x₁ será: -(-11) +, bueno todo esto ya sabemos que
es 81, entre 2(2), entonces me quedará: menos por
menos es más 11 + 9 / 4, es decir 20 / 4, lo cual
es igual a 5 y x₂ = -b - √b² - 4ac / 2a, es decir
x₂ = -(-11) menos la raíz cuadrada de, bueno, ya
sabemos que todo esto es 81, entre 2(2). Entonces
me quedará que: x₂ = 11 - 9 / 4, es decir, 2/4
que es lo mismo que 0.5, entonces cruzaremos al
eje X en 0.5 y 5, y como a tiene signo positivo,
entonces es una parábola que se va a ver de esta
forma. Así que ya está, tenemos la descripción
de la posición de la parábola en un sistema de
coordenadas rectangulares que representa
a una función cuadrática. Ya sabemos que,
con la ayuda del discriminante, nuestra función
cuadrática puede intersecar al eje X en un punto,
en dos o en ninguno. Y, bueno, eso es todo
por este video. Nos vemos en el siguiente.